my brand new tonight we have even more
text messages from Trump hating FBI
officials Peter struck and Lisa Paige
now Senator Ron Johnson has put out a
report that is raising questions about
President Obama's potential involvement
in Hillary Clinton's email investigation
now during a September 2nd 2016 exchange
about creating talking points for former
FBI director James Comey to give to
President Barack Obama Paige writes
POTUS wants to know everything we are
doing all right so what exactly did
President Obama want to be briefed on
now sources close to struck and Paige
they're telling The Wall Street Journal
tonight that this message they sent
doesn't have to do with the Clinton
email probe and instead was talking
about possible Russian interference in
the election so in light of the new
struck text well we need to know one
investigation that Obama want to be
briefed on that's why tonight we have
two very simple questions for Barack
Obama and frankly everyone else involved
in this scandal take a quick look what
did the president know and when did he
know it all right that was Senator
Howard Baker that was during the
Watergate investigation asking very
important questions that President
Barack Obama and others now need answers
to they got to answer to everybody what
did reach out we did reach out to Obama
spoke sir we didn't get to comment from
all of them and by the way shocking also
tonight there's a new batch of text
messages that was just released from the
Trump hating FBI lovers Peter struck and
Lisa page it highlights their
investigative bias and of course their
continued hatred of Donald Trump on
August 9th 2016 Lisa page writes
well he's not ever going to become
president right right now their hatred
for Trump only grows from there on
November 3rd 2016 only days before the
election page wrote well the new york
times probability numbers are dropping
every single day i'm scared for our
organization now the senate report notes
this is likely a reference to the new
york times election forecast which
showed Trump gaining ground at that
point in the election then on Election
Day November 8 2016 struck then says oh
my god this is blanking terrifying and
the next day struck follows up with a oh
my god I am so
depressed and a few days later on
November 13th here's what Lisa page
texts pay close attention to this well I
bought all the President's Men I figured
I needed a brush up on Watergate and the
following day Paige writes God being
here makes me angry
lots of highfalutin national security
talk and meanwhile we have our task
ahead of us okay
what tasks are they talking about now
struck and Paige also called Trump an
idiot lonesome human being talked about
their insurance policy in Casey one so
clearly they were abusively biased
towards now President Donald Trump and
here's what's very important Peter
struck and to an extent Lisa Paige who
was Andrew McCabe's legal counsel there
at the center of everything in all of
this now struck was a former top
intelligence official at the FBI and
signed the documents remember to start
the Russia investigation and struck also
played a key role in the Clinton
investigation even interviewing Hillary
and helping James Comey write that
exoneration months before the
investigation and of course by
overseeing the interviews of not only
Clinton but also general Flynn and by
the way he's the one guy who helped put
the fix in one of a couple and that
allowed Hillary Clinton to remain in
this presidential race otherwise very
likely if it was a fair investigation
she probably would have been indicted
and a new text message proves that on
September 28 2016 struck says got called
up to Andy's earlier who we think is
Andrew McCabe hundreds of thousands of
emails turned over by weiners attorney
to the SD NY the Southern District of
New York includes a ton of material from
spouse that means uma Abidine sending
team up tomorrow to review this will
never end here's why this is important
according to reports what's in the
upcoming DOJ Inspector General report we
expect next month is what caused Andrew
McCabe to abruptly resign at the end of
last month and The Wall Street Journal
is reporting that the FBI officials top
officials including McCabe they knew
about uma Aberdeen's emails that were
found on Anthony Weiner's laptop in
September of 2016
but they waited for at least a month
before alerting Congress
now that text message provides very key
proof that's showing that Comey McCabe
and others they literally sat at a
crucial moment on Ummah avid ease emails
that were discovered on Anthony Weiner's
laptop now the question is why and what
took them so long to notify Congress
which they should have done now the IG
report is due out in the spring probably
of March and hopefully those questions
will be answered there are also other
text messages from struck and page that
are raising a lot of red flags tonight
on May the 19th
two days after Robert Muller was named
the special counsel struck was talking
about joining the investigation with
Muller and struck ask page this question
an investigation leading to impeachment
why are they talking about impeachment
I'll keep in mind during that same text
exchange on May 19th
two days after Robert Muller was named
Special Counsel struck says well you and
I both know the odds are nothing if I
thought it was likely I'd be there no
question I hesitate in part because of
my gut sense and concerned that there's
no big there there hmm so struck knew
from the start that Muller would be
carrying out a witch hunt pretty much
there's also new revelations about
former attorney general Loretta Lynch
and her involvement in the Clinton email
coverup in June 2016
Bill Clinton infamously remembered meets
with Loretta Lynch on the tarmac in
Phoenix for 40 minutes which caused
Lynch to say on July 1st she's stepping
away for the investigation and she would
just accept the FBI's conclusion now
keep in mind all of this is before
Hillary Clinton was ever interviewed by
the FBI
so after Lynch's statement that she was
taking a back seat she would go along
with the FBI and James Comey the same
guy that she said don't call it an
investigation call it a matter struck
then rights to page Oh timing looks like
hell and page replies yeah that's awful
timing and then page later adds it's a
real Profile in Courage since she
Loretta Lynch knows no charges will be
brought by the way they hadn't
interviewed Hillary yet and four days
later call me holds his press conference
right after they interviewed Clinton and
that was Struck's interview and they let
Clinton off the hook so Paige struck
Lynch Comey all-new
Clinton wouldn't be charged and the
Obama administration in fact was rigging
it and the fix was in all right also
tonight even more evidence that the FBI
lied to a FISA Court using that Clinton
bought and paid for dossier to spy in
the Trump campaign now last night we
explained in depth about the unredacted
details in the Grassley Graham memo here
are the highlights of you are with us
now the phony dossier in fact did make
up the bulk of that FISA application and
in March of 2017 James Comey he briefed
Congress that the FBI used the dossier
in a FISA application because they
thought Christopher Steele was credible
so call me oh he just trusted steel
why bother verifying it he didn't now
the FBI only vaguely referenced the
dossiers political origins to the FISA
Court so what they were doing was hiding
the fact they didn't tell the FISA Court
judge in their application that that
dossier that they didn't verify was
bought and paid for by Hillary Clinton
now the Senators also accused steel of
materially misleading the FBI now steel
was working on a second dossier remember
we told you last night and he in part
this takes the cake was being fed
information from the Obama State
Department and Clinton cronies Clinton
associates Wow so they're giving
literally Clinton's friends are giving
steel some of the information he's using
in that phony dossier but the rest of
the information came from the Russian
government remember he was saying that
government was the source for the phony
dossier material now steel was briefing
several mainstream media outlets these
lies in propaganda in the summer and
fall of 2016
about his first fake news dossier and
according to British Court records
Steele talked to reporters let's see
from the New York Times fake news
Washington Post Yahoo News New Yorker
and of course the whole network fake
news CNN at the end of September 2016
about the dossier and we previously
uncovered the fusion GPS co-founder
remember Glenn Simpson he actually
testified to a congressional committee
that the Clinton campaign and the DNC
were very aware that his company was
contacting media outlets they were
coordinating in other words about the
dossier coordinating their
efforts to leak these Russian lies and
also remember the Senate report says the
dossier as we told you last night
full of information from the Russian
government Wow there really is a Russia
collusion story
Hillary Russia collusion then of course
there's the Republican House
Intelligence Committee memo remember the
highlights from that document the former
deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe
revealed to Congress without that
dossier the FISA warrant to surveil
would never have been approved
now the FISA judge was in fact in this
particular case never notified that the
dossier was bought and paid for again by
the Hillary Clinton and the DNC funneled
through the same law firm which of
course is a huge problem and we also
know that James Comey Andrew McCabe
Sally Yates Dana
Bente and rod Rosenstein all approved
surveilling in this particular case now
the FBI also used the Yahoo News article
written by Michael Isikoff
about the Carter trip to Russia they
were using it as separate an independent
source to corroborate the phony dossier
before the FISA judge except the source
for the yahoos story was of course
Christopher Steele so the FBI never
actually corroborated the information
but the steel was the source of the
dossier and the fake news story by
Michael Isikoff and we also know that no
one ever verified what was in the
dossier and of course the memo shows
that Steele was let's see suspended and
terminated as an FBI source for leaking
to the press demoted DOJ official Bruce
or had a close relationship with Steele
and remember or is the guy who had an
office four doors down from the Deputy
Attorney General rod Rosenstein who
would later appoint robert muller and
ors wife Nelly I want to talk about just
coincidences in life Oh
or his wife was employed by fusion GPS
specifically working on the anti-trump
opposition research and Bruce or said
that Steele said quote he was desperate
the author of the da C desperate the
Donald Trump not get elected and was
passionate about him not being President
and finally tonight the memo finds that
during the first FISA application for
that warrant corroboration of the
steeled dossier was in quote its infancy
stage they never verified the Russian
paid for lies by Hillary and the DNC so
the FBI lied to a FISA Court judge
they used a dossier full of Russian lies
to spy on the Trump campaign just before
an important American election and
America's powerful tools of intelligence
will weaponize to spy on an opposition
campaign during an election year
now the key people involved need to
explain themselves